monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues mieux chez
moi mieux pour ma planète voici le
slogan qui présente ma prime rénove aide
au financement des travaux de rénovation
énergétique calculez en fonction des
revenus et du gain écologique des
travaux travaux principalement
d'isolation et de chauffage qui doivent
être effectués par des entreprises
labellisées RGE lorsque votre logement
est mal isolé ou équipé d'un mode de
chauffage dont le coût augmente de façon
exponentielle vous êtes évidemment
intéressé par ce dispositif quand vous
cliquez sur le site vous lisez une aide
accessible à tous propriétaires ou
copropriétaires
occupant ou bailleurs qui s'adapte à la
situation de chacun et favorise les
rénovations ambitieuses cela paraît
simple et attractif si dans de nombreux
cas pardon les démarches aboutissent et
les primes sont versées dans un délai
raisonnable certains dossiers
connaissent des difficultés importantes
et les aident arrivent tardivement
jusqu'à 10 mois après les travaux
numéro national 08 injoignable
difficulté pour accéder à l'interface
dossier accepté dans un premier temps
puis refuser pour l'usager ces 15 jours
maximum pour compléter ou corriger un
dossier mais des semaines sans réponse
de la part du service ma prime rénov
ainsi de nombreuses personnes se
trouvent en difficulté financière quand
les travaux sont à payer et que la
notifié par l'État se fait attendre
c'est aussi le cas de d'entreprises
d'artisans RGE qui remplissent les
dossiers pour leurs clients et qui
attendent longtemps les paiements des
primes fragilisant ainsi leur trésorerie
même des référents préfecture ont des
difficultés à avoir des retours des
dossiers en souffrance alors monsieur le
ministre que comptez-vous faire pour
améliorer ce dispositif et ne pas mettre
particulier et entreprises en difficulté